Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go and take a
look at light properties and settings. So let's get started.
So one of the some of the things that you have control of
when it comes to your lights is your typical settings where
you can control intensity, but there's also unit settings
where on certain lights, not all of them, you're able to
control your unit lists, or you can have candelas or lumens
or EVs for calculation. And you'll see 100 watts equals
about 1600 lumens, EV equals exposure value, which means you
can set intensities and relative stops or powers of two
increments. The directional light is strictly Lux and those
changes aren't available. So some of the things you have
control of and we're going to go over in a real how to mess
with these and edit them is you have indirect light
intensity attenuation, use temperature source radius, source
angle directional light only inverse score fall off in IES
profiles. So you can see on a light outside of directional
light, we have a pull down here underneath intensity units,
and you can then go ahead and choose which one that you
want to use. Now unreal is set, and you should know this
from your foundation classes that any settings that you
make, you can simply click on this arrow with a little curve
on it to set it back to default. So you can easily test
things. But you'll also notice that there's mobility right
below where we have location, rotation and scale. And this
mobility allows us to choose how our lights going to be
calculated in our scene. Now static is for baked and so is
stationary. Both of these are used in such a way so
static will affect only the static objects and stationary can
affect static objects but also objects that are moving. Now
that light does not move in a big setting. The most expensive
light is your movable light. But in a lumen setting, movable
is the standard of light mobility that you need to set
everything to so that your light updates dynamically and
has the GI available to be able to have that light
calculated using the lumen system, as well as virtual
shadow maps. And it's preferable that you use nanite
too. So let's go ahead in Unreal and take a look at
static, stationary, and some of the settings when it comes to
messing with your lights. So let's go ahead in Unreal, take
a look at some light properties and how they work
when using lumen. We will eventually talk about setting
up a lumen but I want to get you familiar first up with what
you can do with the lights. And then we can talk about the
proper settings that will help you get in the right spot
when working with this particular tool. So we have
several lights we can choose from. Let me pull this up so
you can kind of see it and it mirrors what my lecture says.
So let's go to place actors here. And we're going to
simply click on lights. You can see here we have the
directional light, spotlight, the sky light, the point
light and the rec light. Now we'll briefly talk about HDR
backdrop. And we'll briefly talk about sun and sky. But
for the most part, we're going to focus on these five
here. So I have some already in our scene. One of them is
our directional light. Now this directional light is
fantastic for getting things up and running for your outdoor
environments. And yes, they can also influence your
indoor environments as they can shine in through windows,
and other openings that you have in your scene, kind of
like what I have here. But I'm not entirely enclosed in
my scene and have a few other lights that are playing a
role. Now, when using lumen, you want to make sure that
each one of your lights are set in the movability
category. And let me move this up a bit. And you want
to make sure they're set to movable. That's very
important. That's going to allow us to have a totally
dynamic light that we can actually rotate. And as we
do, Unreal will update using lumen, giving us the
best possible look for our environment. Now you'll notice
there's a bit of a refresh that is happening here as I
rotate. So keep those things in mind with your
materials and your environment. And we'll talk about
speeding that up GPU wise in the post process volume
that actually can help a little bit. So the
direction light is great, we can actually control our
locks and how many we need for a particular time of
day. And that's really up to you because you can
look up Hey, what is the locks for a particular
day, maybe it's like, you know, I'm noticing that the
locks for this is like 7000. Now some of these
numbers, when you punch them in, they may not do a
one to one. So some of this is going to be exactly
your kind of interpretation of what you want. I have
simply have 10 in here and actually works pretty good
for a nice little evening type of environment. Looks
like it's 100. So let's switch that to 10. There
we go. And a nice evening day setting here. So
that's really up to you how you want to interpret
that. So we have like color we can choose, as well
as a source angle. Now source angle is key, which
you saw me kind of mentioned before, if you mess
with source angle, we can go in here. And you can
see as I increase that we can soften the edges of
our shadow. So you can see that right there. Now
this is mentioned in the slides, how you can
control this to get a crisp shadow versus a
softer shadow. And you can definitely see it as
I crank this up. So this can be the difference
between a nice direct light that is happening
with not a lot of interference from the
environment and so forth, to maybe a lot of cloud
cover where you have a full on overcast day, and
you're going to kind of get a little bit of a
double blur kind of double exposure there. You
also see there's a source soft angle, you're
probably wondering what that means. Well, what
that does, it makes it if I was to crank this
up and mess with this number, it makes it so
that in the reflection, we're softening the
results that are coming through on this reflective
materials. Now, not quite getting a hotspot of a
circular object, but you're going to see it a
little bit more with some of the other lights.
That's pretty much what it does. It softens the
source of reflectivity that is coming through
from that source there. So the reflectivity
object in those reflective surfaces will get a
little bit softer. So we also can control the
temperature if we want to use the temperature,
you can use that and then crank up those
numbers as needed. I rarely use this one, but
it is available for those that are keen to
that. You can tell it to affect the world or
cast shadows. Now, I don't want to go too
much into button ology because we do get dive
into these a bit deeper in some of the more
advanced lighting courses. But I wanted you to
understand the control that you have. You'll
notice we also have indirect lighting
intensity. So for some of those, it's almost
like you're manipulating your bounces. So you
can actually think of it that way. How strong
is this a light indirectly influencing other
objects. And at the bottom, we have
volumetric scattering intensity. Now this makes
it so that it affects fog. And we talked
about that more in our atmospheric lighting
class. So all these are at our fingertips here.
And the nice thing about working with a
directional light, again, it is our key
environment light for our scene, and allows us
to be able to manipulate things the way that
we need. And you can see it's updating pretty
nicely. But you'll also see there's a bit of a
refresh with the materials. Now you'll notice
if you're using 5.4, and you're converting to
5.5, you may get a weird flicker on the
horizon line. That's because some of the math
has changed what you can do to fix that is
simply rebuild your lighting using this
particular tool. Let me get that up here and
call it environment light mixer. We'll talk
about that towards the end of the class when
the environment light mixer can get you up
and running for your environment really
quickly. And if you need to, you can just
gut all the accessories that are in there. And
what I mean by that is if I open up the
environment light mixer, you're going to see
that we have active a directional light,
skylight, sky atmosphere and volumetric cloud.
If you just delete those in your scene and
then rebuild them using this tool, that
should get rid of that weird screen space
flickering on the horizon line. It's a little
strange. Well, that's it for this video. In
the next video, we're going to look at the
other lights that we have such as the
spotlight, the skylight, point light and
rec light. Thanks again.